plus 15 2 we woke up and I’m already
manually blowing up the price of witches on the trade winds a
lot of dust we were in the basement
crawled out through the
decoctions of the Earth
next door, it’s a pity having looked in Vince’s income all the
three-ruble note was even before the epicenter of the impact And we
were from the three-ruble note further
the windows opened
this very door opened
poured  stones were falling on the roof
at first they didn’t understand us around here just on the
seventh they shot there they shot the same
noise was
called back in general today in the morning we
found out that they got here more
like they woke up from the fact that the glass in the apartment was
broken the windows were broken the doors and
not only the
complex to the palace  another edition where I
live and everything is also broken there Well,
probably not to get
pleasure
from this because we feel bad
That they want us to
also bomb and shoot at city houses
in theirs and so on, but we will not do this
in order to
be different  from them, within a day, the
Armed Forces of the Russian Federation
continued to strike with high
-precision long-range weapons  of military and
sea-based
energy management systems of Ukraine, as
well as arsenals with ammunition and
weapons of foreign production,
all designated objects were hit during the
counter-battery fight,
two artillery batteries of the
armed forces of Ukraine were defeated in the areas of the
settlements of Trifonovka, another
Mykolaivka, Kherson region, as well as a
platoon of American
highmax multiple launch rocket systems in the area of ​​​​the
settlement of Drobyshev Donetsk
sound such as a
helicopter
then cotton is good the hut shook